un remède de cheval pour freiner
l'inflation galopante la banque du
canada fait passer son taux directeur à
2 ni % une hausse d'un point du jamais
vu en près de 25 à l'inflation est trop
élevé et plus de gens ont peur que cette
situation continue on ne peut pas
laisser ça arrivait alors qu'elle
prévoit que l'inflation va demeurer
autour de lui pour cent au cours des
prochains mois la banque centrale veut
donner un coup de barre les pressions
inflationnistes proviennent de plus en
plus du marché intérieur la demande en
biens et services dépasse l'offre ce qui
fait grimper les prix l'économie
surchauffe ce qui a commencé comme une
inflation mondiale causée par les prix
élevés de l'énergie et des biens est en
train de se généraliser au canada la
banque du canada est en mode sauve qui
peut pour établir son autorité sa
crédibilité en matière de ciblage de
l'inflation alors que l'on craint qu'une
spirale inflationniste s'installe
l'économiste jimmy jean se dit d'accord
avec la hausse d'un point décrété
aujourd'hui qu'on refasse c'est vraiment
assuré les ménages et les entreprises
quant au fric on est très agressif et
qu'on voit éventuellement avoir le
dessus
c'est la quatrième hausse du taux
directeur depuis mars ceux qui ont des
prêts hypothécaires à taux variable sont
directement touchés et selon royal
lepage les hausses de taux ont déjà
poussé certains acheteurs hors du marché
immobilier la cara tipp ex fataki aussi
par une inflation domptée un grand coup
l'acquisition qui alimente l'inflation
l'inflation y attaquer son panier
d'épicerie ces moyens de transport
personnellement je n'ai pas encore
acheté mais allait j'allais le faire
cette année c'est sûr que maintenant il
faut jouer allait réfléchir un peu plus
sur youtube avec migros et pas
toujours avec tout l'inflation qui est
partout faut contrôler un pull à la
masse monétaire le policer soir se
développer à l'infini on voit éclore
pour les canadiens on est là avec de
l'aide aux familles on est là avec de
l'aide aux aînés la banque du canada
estime que le taux directeur devrait
grimper encore davantage pour endiguer
l'inflation
il admet que sa marge de manoeuvre est
de plus en plus petit pour accomplir
cette tâche sans trop perturber
l'économie canadienne alors que certains
craignent une récession historique vieux
machins radio canada montréal